thank you
do some of my passwords
I used to have a shirt in high school
that said technology must be used to
liberate the individual and I didn't
really know what it meant for years
because I didn't really think about it
but today I look back and I'm like oh
man hell yeah I like that shirt I'm glad
I wore that shirt because it's how I
really feel today
my name is Daniel Moross today is May
3rd 2012.
go through college and watch the
internet come and all these different
things and now like Bitcoin
it's just a single technology built on
top of the internet but it's so
fascinating because there's so many
freaking things you can do with it and
it's also just a big experiment there's
no guarantees with it
we might just all be wasting our time
exploring Concepts and ideas it's like
this Crossroads of technology and
philosophy and politics and everything
and just be a part of it it's fun it's
crazy though but it's fun
um first question is what is bitcoin
I can't tell you what Bitcoin is in just
a few sentences
it takes time to understand it
the same way it took people time to
understand what the internet was
back in 1994
internet is uh that massive computer
network the one that's becoming really
big now Allison can you explain what
internet is
foreign
was taking off I was in college at
Virginia Tech studying computer science
looking back it's amazing to think about
how much the world was changing
hey Dan ready for the game I'm just
finishing up here with my new kayaking
friends kayaking friends on your
computer yeah I just got America online
that same type of innovation is
happening again with Bitcoin it's the
smartest people in the room that are the
most excited about this so what are they
seeing
the internet changed the way the world
communicates
Bitcoin changes the way money works you
can basically
put a bank in your pocket
I want to buy some secret stuff there is
now a new note that people are starting
to talk about the Bitcoin the money of
the future
coin was created to provide an
alternative to the banking system we're
in the midst of a serious financial
crisis and the federal government is
responding with decisive action
[Music]
unlike most currencies Bitcoins are
issued according to a set of fixed rules
the idea was to create money whose value
couldn't be manipulated by a central
Authority
the government no matter how many guns
they draw cannot
change a mathematical problem
they can point their guns at two plus
tube is always going to equal four
[Music]
fascinating to imagine what it means to
have Global decentralized money
[Music]
and that's what's happening
foreign
[Music]
Burgers is ready second round's going on
in a second
first round
Dan's always been an idea guy
bitcoin's perfect combination of how can
I change the world and make it better
but how can I also be a nerd
so mostly I've just been supporting him
and this craziness
Eliza and I met in college and we've
been married for seven years
we live in Pittsburgh where I'm from and
we have three boys
I've spent most of my career as a
database administrator
but for the past two years I've been
consumed with Bitcoin
Bitcoins come into existence through a
process called mining
I build computers to mine for Bitcoins
[Music]
I'm glad that it's finally getting a
little bit cooler up
my wife won't be as angry that the
basements are so hot
still got a bunch of mining rigs running
right now actually they're right down
here if you want to go take a look
here they are
so what is bitcoin Bitcoin is a
revolutionary technology that enables a
new way to send payments over the
internet
you can think of it as an open
accounting system where thousands of
computers all over the world work
together to track ownership of digital
tokens called Bitcoins
when you send someone Bitcoins the
transaction is broadcast to the entire
network
after it's verified it's recorded in a
public Ledger called the blockchain the
blockchain contains a record of every
Bitcoin transaction that has occurred
since the system began and it's shared
and maintained on the network so
everyone keeps the books so to speak
most currencies are issued by a central
Authority that controls the money supply
Bitcoin is a peer-to-peer system so
there is no Central Authority
instead Bitcoins are issued to users who
help process transactions in the network
this is known as Bitcoin mining
Bitcoin miners are specialized computers
that do the work required to verify and
record transactions in the blockchain
as a reward for their work the miners
earn Bitcoins and this is how new
Bitcoins are released into circulation
the system is programmed so that only 21
million Bitcoins will ever exist and as
time goes by the mining reward decreases
the result is a predictable Supply
that's governed by scarcity making
Bitcoin somewhat like a digital gold
it's the first currency of the internet
and everyone is free to use it
with Bitcoin you can send any amount of
money to anyone anywhere in the world as
easily as sending an email
[Music]
my brother Nick is a filmmaker after
hearing me talk about Bitcoin
incessantly for months we decided to
start documenting things
hey I don't think we'll need the small
camera
it hurts I don't
Mark damn you really cramped it up huh
that's not bothering me geez okay
I was convinced that Bitcoin was going
to be huge and I knew there were a lot
of others like me out there
zip my keys in my pocket so don't forget
them later
[Music]
guy named Toshi Nakamoto invented in 09
by a fictitious person named Satoshi
Nakamoto on Halloween 2008 someone using
the name Satoshi Nakamoto posted on a
cryptography mailing list I've been
working on a new electronic cash system
that's fully peer-to-peer with no
trusted third party the post contained a
link to a white paper in which Satoshi
proposed a new type of payment system
for the internet
it described a protocol that used
peer-to-peer networking proof of work
and public key cryptography
[Music]
for years computer scientists had been
experimenting with these Technologies to
create digital money
but Satoshi discovered a way to combine
them that had never been done before
in doing so he invented Bitcoin
there are no records of nakamoto's
existence prior to the creation of
Bitcoin on his profile page he claimed
to be a 34 year old man living in Japan
although Satoshi Nakamoto is a Japanese
name he wrote in perfect English when
communicating online and went through
Great Lengths to keep his identity
unknown
[Music]
nonetheless programmers and
cryptographers all across the world
recognize the Brilliance of satoshi's
design and began collaborating with him
to further develop Bitcoin
in October of 2009 the first exchange
rate was published listing the value of
1 309 Bitcoins at one dollar
Bitcoins were cheap and through the
following year they continued to trade
for fractions of ascent
in the spring of 2010 a Florida man
named Laszlo decided to try using his
Bitcoins to purchase something
he offered 10 000 Bitcoins to anyone who
would buy him Pizza a man in London
accepted and placed a long distance
phone call ordering him two pizzas from
Papa John's this is generally
acknowledged as the first Bitcoin
transaction for a tangible good
Bitcoin was gaining momentum but in
order for it to thrive the coins needed
to be more widely accessible
a tokyo-based exchange named Mount gox
was the first on the scene to take hold
of the marketplace and trading volumes
started to pick up
by November 2010 already 4 million
Bitcoins had been mined and The Exchange
price briefly spiked to 50 cents per
coin
the market awoke and Bitcoin was
starting to look like it might have real
potential as a currency
his name is Julian Assange Assange and
his colleagues collect confidential
information and then make it public the
release of 250 000 State Department
documents no doubt presents a serious
dilemma for this country
following a massive release of secret
U.S diplomatic cables donations to
WikiLeaks were blocked by Bank of
America Visa Mastercard PayPal and
Western Union an article in PC World
suggested that Bitcoin could be used as
a workaround to send donations to
WikiLeaks
one of satoshi's last known posts was in
response to the article and stated it
would have been nice to get this
attention in any other context Wikileaks
has kicked the Hornet's Nest and the
Swarm is headed towards us
shortly after that Satoshi disappeared
from the forums and was never heard from
again
two months later the Silk Road Anonymous
Marketplace was launched it functioned
as an online black market for drugs and
other illicit goods and used Bitcoin
exclusively because it made the money
Trail nearly impossible to trace
the Silk Road caught the attention of
New York Senator Charles Schumer who was
outraged and publicly called for a
Crackdown on the site
heroin opium cannabis ecstasy
psychedelic stimulants it's unbelievable
throughout all this The Exchange price
continued to climb by February of 2011
Bitcoin reached parity with the US
dollar sparking an influx of new users
and speculators by June the price had
soared to a peak of thirty one dollars
before it came crashing down
as the market tanked the mount Cox
exchange was hacked further shaking the
confidence of investors and hammering
the price all the way down to the two
dollar range by October while Bitcoin
enthusiasts kept hope Skeptics were
quick to share their hindsights and
rants on blogs and in news articles
many thought that the party was over and
that Bitcoin was on its way out
I went online and I bought one Bitcoin
last night really
it's the future I don't know it didn't
feel real oh Real's Gonna Change
just watch
today I sent a total of
2700 Bitcoins to Butterfly laps I
purchased basically a custom designed
Bitcoin mining supercomputer if Bitcoin
fails
[Music]
everything I have is worthless and the
the Bitcoins I have the computers the
mining systems was all a waste of money
um
[Music]
but if it succeeds then uh
it will have been worth it I think
the Bitcoin economy was a wild west in
cyberspace that was very attractive to
hackers and scammers
over the years tens of thousands of
coins had been stolen and 2012 proved no
different
users had to be careful if somebody
steals your Bitcoins there are no
consumer protections sorry they're gone
you lost your Bitcoins they're gone and
you're not going to get them back
but after months of stagnation on the
exchanges the Bitcoin price was on the
rise again price of Bitcoin today is
around seven dollars USD which has had a
nice little bump this week
by the end of the year the blogging site
WordPress announced it would start
accepting Bitcoin payments
and in early 2013 the discussion forum
Reddit also announced Bitcoin support
they were the first major sites to
incorporate Bitcoin and these Milestones
signaled the beginning of mainstream
acceptance
[Music]
Bitcoin is the most subversive
technology on the planet this is a
system that is growing around the entire
world so if it works if this experiment
continues to grow it doesn't just help a
few of us in this state or in the
country but it actually helps everyone
around the world
as the Bitcoin price hovered around its
previous all-time high of 31 dollars I
visited a Libertarian conference in New
Hampshire
and then it gained 20 in 20 minutes it
was it was selling
Libertarians are among the earliest
adopters of Bitcoin its nature is a
currency that isn't controlled by
central banks makes it attractive to
this community once I was able to kind
of grok the basic concept it was just
like this is the perfect money
this is what a Bitcoin address looks
like think of this long string of
characters as an account number where
your Bitcoins are stored
when you send or receive Bitcoins they
are sent to these addresses the
addresses are long and hard to remember
so using a phone to scan a QR code is a
fast and easy way to read them
another good thing to know is that
Bitcoins can be broken down to eight
decimal places this means that you can
send fractions of a Bitcoin so any
amount of money can be represented
with Bitcoin every transaction is public
everyone can see the amount that's being
sent without necessarily knowing the
identity of the sender
these guys even have one of the first
Bitcoin ATMs you just scan your QR code
on your phone put in the dollar bills
and press the button
bam done perfect you now traded your
worthless piece of paper for real
currencies it's like End the Fed it's
like seriously you're gonna hit the FED
you're not gonna defend you're not going
to change anything about the trans and
bypass them right yeah that's what you
should do my concern is how the
governments will react
they can't kill or stop Bitcoin but they
could impede it and they could get in
the way of its development
[Music]
foreign
a few weeks later across the ocean a
financial crisis was reaching a breaking
point on the island of Cyprus Cyprus is
on the brink of going bus the rest of
Europe has agreed to a bailout but only
if Cyprus raids people's bank accounts
for quick Hard Cash people trying to get
money out of the cash machines but
electronic transfers have been stopped
never did I think that they would in a
completely unprecedented manner resort
to stealing money from People's Bank
account
the cypriots had placed their trust in
the banking system
and it had failed them
as news of the crisis spread around the
world Bitcoin Believers were quick to
point it out as an example of why a
currency free from government control is
needed there's actually Bitcoin ATMs
apparently being set up in Cyprus all of
a sudden Bitcoin looks like an
attractive Prospect
[Music]
while this was happening in Cyprus
Regulators at the U.S treasury weighed
in on bitcoin
the financial crimes enforcement Network
known as fincen issued its first
regulatory guidance on Virtual
currencies
the guidance implied that Bitcoin in and
of itself was not illegal
[Music]
it was The Perfect Storm
the situation in Cyprus suggested that
Bitcoin could function as a financial
Safe Haven
and the approving nod of U.S Regulators
was a green light for investors
the market agreed and The Exchange price
continued to climb
moving from the the super super early
adopter phase to possibly the early
adoption phase
Bitcoin was getting International
exposure
and people were starting to pay
attention
this is actually a live updated map of
the globe and the lines represent uh
Bitcoin clients basically where the
Bitcoin software is running
and uh the length of the line determines
how long it's been online or how active
it's been and every time I look at this
I swear it gets it gets more and more
saturated you can almost see an outline
of the US now South America you're
starting to get it but the big news in
my opinion is this China you used to see
one two three maybe and this is all
within the last you know three weeks or
so that's the most I've ever seen in
China you look down here Indonesia
Singapore Australia New Zealand
foreign
week at snowed in Pittsburgh
I was eagerly awaiting the delivery of
two Avalon Asics
state-of-the-art computers with chips
specifically designed for mining
bitcoins ifuguo is at the Forefront of
the new generation of hardware and is
the first to bring them to Market
everybody including myself has severely
underestimated that the mining Market of
how big it is when Bitcoin began a
standard laptop was powerful enough to
mine hundreds of Bitcoins in a matter of
days
the technology evolved rapidly over the
past couple of years
a lot of people are getting into it
we're still trying to catch up
I was on vacation with my family when
the new miners were scheduled to arrive
the price of Bitcoin had rocketed to 77
dollars so I asked some friends to wait
at my house to get them running as soon
as possible
all right
wow oh definitely
these are new computer parts here
excellent I came from China all right
it's not official till you sign up there
we go
yeah we'll see maybe uh down the road
you guys will start accepting Bitcoin
one day I bet that's cool it's a matter
of time good luck to you guys all right
I notified Dan and he has a little
response here
[Music]
welcome to the financial Renaissance
1681.140-255-255-2550-192-1681.1 that's
the default gateway my first pool to be
stratum.ozco.in Port 3333 Port 80 but I
can do 3333 when everything
's up for at least a little
[Music]
gonna change though after another week
it's going to get dropped down to like
eight just because the difficulty is
just going through the roof because
everybody's clearing these things up so
it's always a race to stay ahead and try
to be the first guy with the hardware
you know
oh I'm getting things yep we're kicking
we are accepting shares it is live
we got the balloon
[Music]
hey that looks like Johann say I'm going
to college because my dad Minds Bitcoins
[Music]
so uh big day today huh big day look at
that 104. current bitcoin price broke
100 today
um it is April Fool's Day price Rising
so insanely high is kind of a little bit
unprecedented so
it's bound to pop a little bit
maybe I don't know maybe it'll be a 225
in a week and a half so who knows but
Bitcoin styles could go up could go down
as the price passed 100 we took a trip
to visit Gavin Andresen
he is known to have worked closely with
Satoshi during bitcoin's early days
[Music]
train tracks and he did say that there
would be train tracks maybe passing
through
there we go this is Gavin's house
Gavin is one of the last people to
communicate with Satoshi before he
disappeared
warning
this is my brother Nick and his wife
Ashley hi nice to meet you found the
place okay so good we're very excited to
be here
at work is where I live
beautiful home
a little higher place right there's
great
got it
how did you first get into Bitcoin tell
us a little bit of the story of how you
got involved I had been working at UMass
as a staff programmer in the computer
science department research group my
wife's a professor at UMass
I actually quit that job before going on
a six-month sabbatical in Australia
I just happened to read a little blurb
on mine in somebody's blog that
mentioned this Bitcoin project which is
an open source attempt to do money
and it caught my interest
I basically just spent a few days
read everything I could about it looked
at the source code downloaded the source
code thought about it and I really
couldn't convince myself that it would
not work it seemed like Satoshi had
thought of everything
it's then
I've just been stuck down the rabbit
hole
Bitcoin is open source software with
open source software the code is
publicly available anyone can look at it
and see how it runs and they can also
contribute their own changes
programmers like Gavin were able to join
Satoshi to work on bitcoin simply
because they were interested over time I
think Satoshi learned to trust me he
could see that I didn't make very many
stupid mistakes I never had any personal
connection with Satoshi it was always
purely business and I think that's
because he was so worried about people
finding out his identity I don't know
why
my last email to him was telling him
that I had agreed to go visit the folks
at the CIA
so
whether that had something to do with
him deciding to cut off communication
with me entirely he had been pulling
away before then but the CIA invited me
to come talk at the CIA and I agreed to
do that
knowing it would surely spark conspiracy
theories Gavin posted an announcement on
the Bitcoin talk discussion forum to
head off any rumors I think accepting
their invitation and being open about
exactly what Bitcoin is will make it
less likely they'll see it as a threat
having taken on the lead developer
position since satoshi's disappearance
Gavin found himself facing an increasing
number of responsibilities in public
scrutiny dear neighbors know that you're
kind of at the center of one of the most
disruptive Technologies I think I think
they know that I do like this wacky
Bitcoin project
I don't think they know quite how big it
is yet
right now
bitcoin's a billion dollar project when
I started it was this tiny little
experiment and as it gets bigger
the pressure
to not screw up
just gets bigger and bigger
two weeks later the price soared past
150. some bitcoiners woke up to find out
they were Bitcoin millionaires
twenty-three-year-old Charlie Schram is
the CEO of a company called bid instant
bit instant was one of the first
startups in the Bitcoin space in
bitcoin's infancy people had to jump
through several Hoops to buy them
one of the only ways was through the
mount gox exchange but this process
required transferring money through
several intermediaries and could take
weeks
Charlie launched bid instant to
streamline this process and to help
people buy Bitcoins quickly
yeah that's good great that's pretty
nice yeah sure
today Charlie's being photographed for
an article in business week
like throwing stuff up in the air and
they're gonna add Bitcoins in later on
yeah
this Bitcoin thing can actually change
the world
but for this thing to succeed you have
to figure out a way to get more money in
and out of the ecosystem
yeah and you can look yeah that's good
it does not show though I'm super
stressed out right now and you know
thousands of orders that are being
processed and I'm bugging out trying to
get the new site launched
I'm trying not to but it's really hard
things have been insane
I haven't slept in days
the price is just Rising so a lot of
people are putting money into it
normally Charlie can get Bitcoins to his
customers in about an hour
but with the recent flood of people
trying to purchase Bitcoins bit instant
can't fill their orders fast enough
when I pulled up our like customer
service interface we have close to 2 000
Open tickets and that's just from
Saturday to this morning nobody was
ready for this kind of volume so
we're trying to catch up uh with the
volume and keep everybody happy
the last week or so saw our our support
staff go from two people to five people
when someone offers you a seat on the
rocket you don't ask where the seat is
you just get on the rocket
further our volume has has basically
tripled in in the past two weeks going
from a few hundred transactions a day to
now two three thousand transactions a
day you just came on board here right
yeah I did actually today is kind of my
first day yeah yeah how does it feel to
be a part of all this madness
um well Madness yeah it's overwhelming
and uh what do you do for Vanessa I'm a
CFO
can you give me like a daily estimate of
how money is moving through your system
um it's in the in the six figures every
day
all right well thanks Kelly I really
appreciate it thank you
I don't know how the government will
react to bitcoin
but I spend thousands of dollars on
lawyers every day just to make sure that
I'm not going to go to jail
it's super terrifying I mean I don't
want to go to jail
uh and I don't it I don't want to become
a martyr either
[Music]
Bitcoin was the Talk of the Town
Charlie was in the Limelight and could
barely keep up with media requests
within hours the price passed two
hundred dollars
first day of spring first day Bitcoin is
over 200. the start of a new era hi nice
to meet you another nice warm loving mom
that makes him live at home because
kids uh we can't apart we have him yet
we love him too much
this is where it all started and this is
where it still goes down
I've been collecting money from all over
the world and it's just like something I
did way before Bitcoin I'm doing this
since I was a kid so it's funny that
like I'm collecting all this fee out
it's not worth anything and then all of
a sudden I get into this Bitcoin thing
I realized during high school that I can
never work for anyone
I made up a term psychologically
unemployable
I started a bit instant while I was
still in my senior year of college
Bitcoin currently is the largest social
economic experiment ever conducted in
the history of the world
2013 possibly 2014 will be the two years
that really make or break Bitcoin
Bitcoin is the first product that's
digital but it's also scarce
I got some good news last night that
part of our licensing deals that we've
been trying to do for the past few
months are finally hopefully coming
through we got approved to be licensed
in 30 of the 48 states in money
transmission
I've been working very hard on trying to
be compliant in the in the legal realm
and with fincen's announcement setting
up a way for Bitcoin companies to
legally exist that really changes the
whole game of Bitcoin and for us it
helped us get that less push that we
needed from all the banks and The
Regulators to finally hopefully get that
licensing that we need
[Music]
today Charlie's meeting with a realtor
to talk about new office space
how are you pleasure got a minute I have
10 minutes for you
we're a company with no boss essentially
everyone has their responsibilities
well it's one big executive board one
person doesn't do their job I don't do
my job these guys are only gonna yell at
me so that's how we do it but we get
things done all right we're outgrowing
the space as you can see here that's a
good problem to have yes now Rachel said
there was a great concern about Security
in this space yeah we're regulated so we
can't like share an office with another
company to get access to us our asset is
our software our software is processing
hundreds of thousands of dollars a day
instantly really quickly and that's on
site here or just no this is on the
cloud it's all in the cloud but we
monitor we have to monitor everything
from here and debug fix take down upload
more put up more videos with a high
volume data that's oriented it's very
very sensitive customer data if it were
not a doorman at the very least the
space would be designed in such a manner
that there'd be a locked reception area
if we want to pursue like the guard at
some point we could have them in that
I absolutely think it it will be at some
point it's just a matter of time
potential for theft is huge it's like
operating a bank essentially
pretty much hit gotcha basic stuff yep
yep all right any other words for me
I think we're good are you willing to
handle the task
sign me up Captain
night the price got as high as 266
dollars
every major news Outlet had taken notice
Bitcoin fever was at an all-time high it
is getting a lot of attention people are
fascinated by anything that makes new
highs every day for weeks on end which
Bitcoin has done in terms of the total
number of the people using the currency
I'm not sure but you can see that
there's a huge amount of fluctuation in
the volume of trading and then the price
crashed
foreign
Bitcoin lost more than half of its value
in six hours
from craze to crash it's the talk of
many people in the Blogger sphere
and it's certainly suffering some
Growing Pains the value of the virtual
currency Bitcoin has plunged it's been a
crazy day today I haven't slept in like
40 hours
your order process I don't understand
why we're still having this conversation
we've refunded the order we sent you
extra Bitcoins
care man when it comes to my money I
don't [__] her out I know man you need
your stuff I hear you I hear you it
processed your Bitcoins are there man
it's Charlie what's been going on today
crazy day huh yeah I have Mount gox
their whole system pretty much failed
and their whole training engine is is
broken
pretty much caused
almost has to shut down for the day
further the Bitcoin price has just been
wildly swinging up and down it was down
100 today it's gaining back up but
mostly because people can't buy and sell
on they can't withdraw and they can't
deposit
the whole thing is just it's just a
Fritz
so what we're trying to do is figure out
a way to mitigate order somewhere else
for now
with Mount Cox stuck in a nosedive the
ripple effect is creating chaos in the
Bitcoin markets
I'm trying to figure out why our orders
aren't going through Rachel am I allowed
to take another Advil if I took one like
an hour ago
they've been having problems ordering
anything off of you yeah I'm getting a
lot of customers emailing saying it says
executed but it's not showing in the
blockchain does God suspend the trading
really yeah awareness play suspended
until 2100 what time what's 2100 it's 9
p.m oh my God
[Music]
foreign
if you bought it 150
and then you're at 260 and then you
watch it dip down back to 150. do you
panic so yeah absolutely I don't know
what a Bitcoin is so I just bought it
you see buy orders people buying
and selling at such a wide range it
doesn't make any sense
the API is just constantly failing is
that what's going on we're not getting
any orders
don't care about the price
speculators can play musical chairs all
day long for all I care I'm I'm long
I was focused on expanding my mining
operation
the only people that are going to be
shaken out by this drop are people that
are new to bitcoin here's The Avalons
spinning away mining away
and if everything goes as planned uh
we'll have 18 more of these guys and a
couple weeks
Bitcoin is a complicated thing you have
to spend some time looking into it and
understanding it before you really care
now there's droves of people that you
know giving it more than just that
glance because the price has gone so
high and they have you know dollar signs
in their eyes like Uncle Scrooge
so much more than that and I think
that's why the people who are mining and
people who believe in it are just kind
of holding strong
foreign
resumed at Mount Cox the price fell even
further to around seventy dollars 71 on
btce
yeah Bitcoin it's a volatile it's gonna
be a long time until we have stability
that's the nature of the Beast price
Discovery uh can be violent and volatile
and there's going to be a lot of people
that come and go and people that scream
off
but at the end of the day the only thing
that really kind of stinks right now is
that everybody's trading on one platform
that isn't doing the greatest job so
over time hopefully we'll see some more
uh exchanges pop up and some more
options and people want to keep using
Bitcoin and I'm sure infrastructure will
come
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just gotten ridiculously busy
um
I get an email every two seconds now and
I'm pretty much you know more email than
I uh
that I can keep up with
Jared Kenna is the CEO of tradehill the
first us-based Bitcoin exchange to
compete with Mount Cox
he's also on the list of Bitcoin
millionaires
this is uh Finnegan right here
Jared runs trade Hill out of a 41
bedroom residential hotel called 20
mission that he also owns
foreign
out rooms to attack people start up
people and there's a lot of bitcoiners I
actually accept rent in Bitcoin which is
great because we have a lot of
international people
[Music]
it came to us from the crypto brand it
came out up in there it saved us from
those nasty dollars on one and yen
Bitcoin that's all I got I'm done
digital currency is gonna happen I mean
it's it's I mean it already is happening
and it will be the future whether that's
now 10 years from now 100 years from now
we're going to be using digital
currencies that don't depend on Fiat
government
Jared originally launched trade hell
about two years ago but ran into
problems with a payment processor and
was forced to shut down
recently he met Ryan Singer and together
they are relaunching the exchange the
business we're in is helping people
speculate right markets are price
Discovery mechanisms that's what they're
for people uh they buy they sell there's
the bid there's the ask and the price
moves and when it levels out that's what
the market price is I can't even count
the amount of people that have said
bitcoin's not backed by anything at
least dollars are backed by gold I've
realized that a lot of people believe
that
my grandfather he got me into investing
when I was a kid I was five years old I
could explain a p e ratio and what it
did in an Ask was and difference between
a limit order and a market order and all
that stuff so for me I saw this as a way
the average person could actually take
control of their finances I just grew up
pretty nerdy I don't know I think like
15 like I
years old I decided I didn't want to be
a nerd anymore
which was a mistake
because
now I realize it's pretty awesome
in 1999 I joined the Marines
I was originally with the engineering
unit
2005 I went over to Afghanistan I was
mostly working with the Afghan National
Army
changed me a lot as a person
I've always been interested in economics
and finance and technology and
cryptography
I was on a cryptography Forum somebody I
never met it was anonymously in this
forum that I was chatting with sent me
10 000 Bitcoins just as a way to test
the system out and see how it worked and
I got them and I'm like well that's cool
but uh what can I do with him and he
said
well nothing yet but uh if people
believe it has value it will
at the time there was really only one
Bitcoin exchange it was Mount gox I said
we need an alternative who cares if the
technology is decentralized and the
method of transfer is decentralized and
the people are decentralized if all the
trades are in the same location
I thought that building another exchange
that gave more people access to bitcoin
would be a key part of bitcoin's growth
the day we launched we got a quarter
million dollars in from user deposits
and we said like oh [__] this is this is
real
we're all fans of The Big Lebowski so
we're going to have a Big Lebowski party
nice
this is uh
very exciting day
30 gallons of white russian and hallway
bowling
we work hard but we party hard too okay
okay I'm good I'm good I'm Not Dead
yeah I'm the first one in the house
that opened the trade Hill account
it took me a long time to visit by the
Bitcoins because it was at the moment
where everything was going really really
you know ballistics
Bitcoins all the time and it was hard to
buy it and it took me like 10 days to
get my Bitcoins from my European bank I
got my Euros over here to open a 10K
account with trade hell at the moment
where they where they were 255 dollars a
Bitcoin
and within one hour they start Plumbing
down and the same day they went down to
99 65 or something or ninety dollars uh
Bitcoin hey stop smiling
[Laughter]
straight out round two we optimized for
Success we launched expecting to have to
do hundreds of thousands of transactions
a second
right now we've got about 15 people in
addition to that we've got about eight
attorneys externally
a lot of people are depositing dollars a
lot of people are passing Bitcoin we're
getting more trading we're pushing that
from the business perspective also we're
talking to people who want to do more
automated trading on our platform get
robots trading against each other
we've stress tested this and we can
handle you know about
500 times as much volume as Mount gox
was seeing so we'll see what happens
here the interest in US is pretty crazy
just the news with Bitcoin has really
kind of validated everything now people
are like oh you're not this crazy person
talking about some digital made-up
currency it's like oh I've read about it
in the Wall Street Journal the New York
Times it's real we had an investor come
in and he said hey I really appreciate
your Scrappy nature and how you're
hustling but I think it's time for you
guys to spend 30 grand a month on rent
when you have you know
billionaire client they want to come
check out your office before they send
you a multi-million dollar wire
asking them to walk past pawn shops is
not always the right field
[Music]
so we're leaving the mission we're
driving into Soma right now we're going
to go take a look at what may be our new
office space
pretty prestigious address one market
[Music]
right now we're trying to forge this
path and we're trying to comply with
existing laws that anticipate future
laws which is extremely expensive and
extremely difficult is there parking
here yes okay is that included with no
of course absolutely right what is that
how much how much does uh how much does
that cost from 450 to 600
it's not terrible whoa
that's pretty sexy
Twitter was here for over a year yeah
Amazon comes and go every single year I
have nice he said I have JCPenney all
the big ones they come over they are
part of the club
sounds good we'll be here tomorrow thank
you appreciate it thanks so much
we're moving tomorrow just like just
like that huh just like that that's how
we roll pretty surprising that that deal
just happened so quickly what was it you
just like the space and you said hey
there's no point in Waiting we'd like
the space we like the address
we don't have the time to spend either
we had all kinds of important stuff
we're working on and you know if we
spend a week trying to find an office
and he and I put 20 hours in 250 hours
until it's a huge waste of time
[Music]
I thought they'd be in multiple bags
rather than one big one but hey
foreign
[Music]
I believe that Bitcoin will do to the
banking industry what email did to The
Postal Service
it didn't make it irrelevant
what has forced the post office to do is
concentrate on their strengths and less
so on their weaknesses
Mike Caldwell is the creator of physical
Bitcoins known as cassatious coins
that are often featured in mainstream
media coverage of Bitcoin
they're a novelty item Collectibles that
basically act as physical carriers for
Bitcoins but they do something very
important they give Bitcoin a face
come on in
sorry the kids are sleeping so I'm just
being quiet
each coin has its own Bitcoin address
and the private key required to spend it
is hidden underneath the Hologram this
is where you make the physical Bitcoin
yeah
it's random smattering of things but
pretty careful about the way I managed
you know the
basically this is the credential so this
is the
hologram and the private keys I'm pretty
careful about those and don't keep them
here I normally do them on this mirror
because that helps you know get the
fronts and backs right
there's so many things that cryptography
can do for us that if the world just
knew so many social problems could be
solved cryptography
can bring fairness to elections
it's too difficult for people to
understand and someone needs to bridge
the gap
right now we're using Bitcoin to send
money
but many believe it will revolutionize
much more
the technology behind Bitcoin can be
used to build decentralized systems with
rules that can't be cheated
foreign
my space this is you know awesome it is
what it is
the more time goes by the more
legitimate Bitcoin gets and the more
proud I am to be associated with it and
now what does your wife do
she does crafts she's a lot like me we
just sit around and make things all day
it's just our obsession
no I'm not a drug dealer no I'm not a
criminal no I'm not a terrorist I
believe in the rule of law I believe in
structure that builds Society I believe
in families I believe in corporations I
believe in all the essential elements
that a civilize Society with Law and
Order need to be able to function
focal length matters
cryptography is the basis for us being
able to implement the values we say we
believe in
this idea will never die
the technology that Bitcoin brought to
the Forefront the genie is out of the
bottle
[Music]
since the crash the Bitcoin price has
been hovering around a hundred dollars
Bitcoin seemed to have weathered the
storm
but there's still much controversy
surrounding the currency
the same cryptography that ensures the
user's privacy
also allows it to be used anonymously
[Music]
my father decided to retire and he had
an old failing print shop I basically
took it over and I converted into an
internet place
we're the only place in La that supports
Bitcoin right now
this is my Linux system here
it's a system that also mines for
Bitcoins
makes about a dollar a day I just do it
for fun
like I was really really into the
internet like literally in 1990 1991
1992 and I had the hardest time
describing what the internet was to
people I was tell people well it's like
this network of computers and the
network of computers can talk with other
networks of computers and then you can
exchange information and like people
would have no idea what it was
when people ask me what Bitcoin is I
have the hardest time describing what it
is and I'd surmise it as it's basically
money it's basically an anonymous PayPal
it's one of those things that you have
to use before you understand
politically I'm not a very big fan of
either the banks or Federal Reserve and
Bitcoin allows me to get around that one
of the programs we support is a protocol
called Tor and basically what Tor does
is it allows you to communicate to a
website anonymously Tor is a program
that allows you to get on a Silk Road
and this is Silk Road
basically any drug you want is available
there's a lot of weed there's a lot of
cocaine there's a lot of Ecstasy but
there's also unusual drugs like if you
want some sort of anabolic steroid you
can type steroid you'll get all the
different types of steroids that are
available Silk Road itself is not
selling the drugs this is basically a
Matchmaker between buyer and seller both
the buyer and seller don't know each
other both the buyer and seller are
Anonymous it goes on this web of trust
if you want to let's say buy this
testosterone you click on this
he has a 99.3 positive feedback from
more than 300 transactions so even
though the contracts aren't enforceable
by law the reputation system makes it so
that the the system works pretty well
oh there's a fireworks section now I
didn't know that
Florida ID
1.88 Bitcoins which is around 150
something like that
a forged auto insurance card
forged passport
there was over 9 000 entries for drugs
that's a lot
I would say there's around maybe five
customers that know about it and use it
it's it's a very small percentage of the
people that come in but the people who
do know about it specifically come here
to use it
what the customers do with the computers
is pretty much their business
in that day in the office
if you're going to do drug dealing of
any sort Silk Road is the place to go
how many people are selling cannabis
right now
it looks like 2011 people are selling
calories they call me Mr Bitcoin
I've probably been getting dressed
because I was like 17.
[Music]
right now I'm 26.
I think it's as a global thing when I'm
on the computer I'm doing business with
the world
let's see they have blue dreams our
diesel pineapple Thai Purple Kush Girl
Scout cookies Purple Haze when I first
heard about it I was laughing about it
it took me a week to just even think
about this for real like I can really
make money off of Internet selling this
type of stuff I mean are you sure about
that
it's something I probably may buy right
here
it has a little like some good kush
and some of these things only take like
a day to get here
with no harassment from nobody instead
of just being on the streets once you
get the hang of it it's actually kind of
fun just looking through different
things
Mr Bitcoin I'm running with it I like
the name you know what I mean I'm not
gonna lie I get booty off this I kind of
like talking about this stuff with girls
like girls like that [__] hot and like
you're not on your street and you got a
little nerd knowledge this is great
I have like a lot of Bitcoin saved up
already my business is doing good it's a
fun way of doing hustling these days
like the future brung a different way to
hustle and I like it
[Music]
with so many people using Bitcoin in so
many different ways it's becoming
apparent that it can't be ignored
foreign
[Music]
a bureau of the U.S department of the
treasury
despite having released guidance on
Virtual currencies there's still a lot
of uncertainty surrounding their outlook
on the future of Bitcoin regulation
straight ahead in the big fish bowl
looking okay great
[Music]
I'm not going to say what you're going
to have every answer for you today but
the
um
I mean what I do want to say is the
you know we didn't want to shut down
Bitcoin
um you know we didn't want to attack
Bitcoin we think
there's a lot of
social benefit to you know kind of had
the Google alert on my computer for
Bitcoin and
once a month once or twice a month
something pop up but now it's five a day
yeah
Jennifer shasky Calvary came on board as
fincen's director last year
during her career she spent 15 years at
the Department of Justice where she
specialized in fighting money laundering
and organized crime virtual currencies
have been on my radar for a while even
prior to coming to this position because
of unfortunately the abuse of some of
them Bitcoin on the other hand is one
that really didn't come on my radar
probably until I arrived at Vinson
who you speak to the issuance of our
guidance was either the best thing that
ever happened to bitcoin or the worst
thing that ever happened to bitcoin some
accusing us of trying to kill Bitcoin
and others saying that it somehow
legitimized it of course neither of
those things I think is is probably true
and certainly neither of those things
was our intent one of the clear lines is
that if you're a consumer who's using
Bitcoins to buy goods and services the
guidance doesn't pertain to you we're
focused more on the places where we
think we have risks to the U.S financial
system from money laundering and
terrorist financing and I think that
might be kind of a lot of the Bitcoin
Community has a little bit of a fear
that you know Bitcoin may be
characterized in a way so as to tie it
to some bad actor ruining it for
everyone and when a lot of people that
are interested in Bitcoin including
myself see it as just you know this
technology that we don't really don't
want to see it you know falling into the
wrong categorization of with all the
potential that's there sure so that
Innovation around Bitcoin and the
virtual economy
is is really one of the more interesting
aspects I think of this story the idea
that it can be used to potentially serve
the unbanked out there just to provide
some really new services that are
convenient for consumers the flip side
of it though is that to be a part of the
financial system the U.S financial
system the Global Financial system also
comes with some responsibilities and
those responsibilities include not
allowing your institution to be used by
criminals and by terrorists
there's always been a concern that the
government might try to Stamp Out
Bitcoin
but perhaps they see the risk of being
left behind
in May 2013 the biggest Gathering to
date of Bitcoin enthusiasts and
entrepreneurs happened in San Jose
California
we're at Bitcoin 2013. it's the
inaugural Conference of the Bitcoin
Foundation
[Music]
coin is worldwide and the vast majority
of people haven't even heard of Bitcoin
yet
it's more powerful than every computer
on the top 500 list combined
it's an awfully big world uh an awful
lot of things could happen really you
know we've been on a roller coaster ride
and I expect at least for the next few
years we're going to remain on a roller
coaster ride
I happen to enjoy roller coasters I
think they're fun
[Applause]
just a few weeks earlier Cameron and
Tyler Winklevoss known for their
involvement in Facebook announced that
they own a one percent stake of all
Bitcoins in existence worth around 11
million dollars
they also made a 1.5 million dollar
investment in Charlie's company bid
instant we started looking seriously at
it at the end of last summer and started
purchasing around that time I think a
light bulb just went off and said wow
like the implications of this could be
enormous if everyone in the world can
have a Bitcoin address and everyone in
the world could be banked fairly quickly
and when you consider that it's a very
powerful idea and Bitcoin can make that
happen we're going all over the world
we're going to the UK we're going to
Australia we're going to we're already
in Russia we're going to South America
we're already in Brazil now you can buy
Bitcoin at any of our locations it's fun
to think that Satoshi might be here too
I always wonder if somebody is someone
here somewhere is uh yes
I was planning to hack security cameras
for the of the hotel and try to trace
the pattern of walk of some person who
might be Satoshi
what would he do what talks would he be
attending you know
we're seeing the Bitcoin players in the
market meeting with the Venture
capitalists and they're all beginning to
posture and that's very exciting because
it means that there's going to be a lot
more infrastructure built out a lot more
money flowing into the space and it's
really going to be a big bull market for
Bitcoin
one of the companies best known for
making Bitcoin accessible for Commerce
is atlanta-based bitpay
they're Pioneers in Bitcoin and provide
a service that enables Merchants to
accept Bitcoin payments without dealing
with its complexities we have grown
about about a factor of 10 since the
beginning of the year we were doing
about half a million dollars a month
around the turn of the year and now
we're doing about five million dollars a
month this is people using Bitcoins to
buy real goods and services they're not
day trading they're not exchanging
they're actually buying things I'm
confident that Bitcoin is the most
important invention in the entire
history of the world since the internet
Roger Vera is an investor in several
early Bitcoin companies including bitpay
his passion and enthusiasm has earned
him the nickname Bitcoin Jesus it is
going to change everything and all of
you here in this room you're at the very
very Forefront of that
[Applause]
Roger lives in Tokyo but travels the
Earth spreading the good word of Bitcoin
the last couple of days we've been
setting up a business per day to accept
Bitcoin here in the Bay Area today's
business is going to be the Super kill
po Korean supermarket so for you like
you accept credit cards right now the
credit card companies are charging you
two or three percent for Bitcoin you can
do the same thing but they'll only
charge you one percent you'll still get
dollars in your bank account if you want
you can choose to split some of the
payments that you receive into Bitcoins
and then summon the dollars in whatever
ratio you want so you can keep 99
dollars and one percent of Bitcoin or 99
in Bitcoin and one percent dollars
however you want you can decide that
Roger is describing the service provided
by bitpay they take the volatility of
bitcoin's price out of the equation for
merchants by immediately converting
Bitcoins to dollars at the time of sale
so right now we have it set to 100
dollars so anybody that pays here with
Bitcoin they'll deposit the money into
your bank account the very next day with
only a one percent fee and I guarantee
you over the next couple weeks you'll
have lots of computer nerds that love
Bitcoins will be coming in here
specifically to shop at your Supermarket
so that they can pay with Bitcoin
the credit card companies just for
processing the payment they take
anywhere from
1.5 percent to over three percent and
then on certain cards there's even a per
transaction fee like 20 cents per
transaction plus the percentage of the
transaction one two percent is Big we're
talking about eleven twelve thousand
dollars a month on the average that they
just take right out of our account I
honestly think that there's a really
good chance that Bitcoin to be more than
a thousand dollars by the end of the
year because everybody who hears about
wait I can send money to and from anyone
I want it's impossible for anyone to
freeze your account it's impossible for
anyone to block you from sending or
receiving these Bitcoins more polish
Euro so you can see all these different
currency exchanges around the world that
exchange to and from Bitcoins and you
can see there's I don't know maybe
between 50 and 100 exchanges now when I
first heard about Bitcoin and started
telling everybody about it if you looked
at that same page there were less than
10.
and there's no central office that they
could rate or anything like that there's
no Central it's amazing there's no
central office there's no central place
they could go to and say take Steve's
Bitcoins or give Steve's Bitcoins to
Kevin or do this or do that that's the
owner of Bitcoins
everybody that owns Bitcoin yeah just
like who's the owner of gold whoever
whoever owns some gold
short of shutting down the entire
internet in the entire world there's no
way to stop Bitcoin
and hit request payment
and that's a QR code for your Bitcoin
address so I'm going to scan that
so now I have your Bitcoin address on my
phone I think this is two dollars
so I'm going to send you two dollars
worth of Bitcoins
[Music]
there it is you just received that many
Bitcoins from me directly with no fee
and if you hit the little green square
it'll show you the equivalent amount in
US dollars
so you just receive two dollars worth of
Bitcoins directly from iPhone to your
phone and you can send money just like
that anywhere in the world you could
have told me your Bitcoin address by
email or post it on Facebook or Twitter
or anywhere so I could print this and
have it at the register yep and you can
you can check right on your phone
anytime that you receive the payment
okay thank you Steve all right thank you
sometimes
one of the newest standouts in the
Bitcoin space is a San Francisco company
named coinbase
they operate a digital wallet service
that makes it simple to buy use and
accept Bitcoin I would not be surprised
at all if Google Square PayPal everybody
is looking at adding Bitcoin in one or
two years by then we need to have 50
million wallets
if we can make this easy to use it's
going to be huge my involvement in
Bitcoin is not politically motivated
yeah dude people are realizing large
capital gains
when professional investors enter the
realm the stakes definitely change we
raised five million dollars from Union
Square Ventures Fred Wilson led the
round there I think Bitcoin is still
actually a little bit under the radar I
think it's moved past the stage where
people dismiss it
but I don't think that it's totally gone
mainstream either I think we're in that
middle stage right now
at the end of the conference Jared from
tradehill threw a party to celebrate how
far things had come you guys are hot
right now dude congratulations on the
race thank you it's good money man it's
well do yeah I mean well
hopefully it's an advancement for the
community I am completely Pro compliance
like I think like if you don't want to
attach your identity this
can't work with you yeah I mean like the
libertarian side of me is like uh yeah
whatever well like from a business
perspective if people don't play by the
rules
you're not gonna last yeah you're gonna
just shut down you're gonna go to jail
noticeably absent from the conference
were representatives of bitcoin's
biggest exchange Mount Cox
just days earlier the Department of
Homeland Security seized more than 5
million dollars from their U.S accounts
the seizure warrant stated that mount
Cox had failed to register as a money
transmitter putting them in violation of
the new fencing guidelines
I'm traveling to Tokyo to meet Mark
karpeles Mount Cox's reclusive CEO
[Music]
no Bitcoins on here
not yet
actually that will make this completely
unnecessary for now it seems kind of
primitive that we're exchanging paper
for paper
and losings and losing that and
someone's taking a cut someone's taking
me a little perceptional
Mark and his business partner gonzag are
French but they operate Mount gox from
offices in Japan
originally Mount gox was in exchange for
trading cards used in a game called
Magic the Gathering
mtgox stood for Magic the Gathering
online Exchange
in 2011 Mark's company tabon bought
Mount gox and his Focus has been Bitcoin
ever since
one of the conditions of my visit is to
refrain from any discussion about the
DHS seizure due to the ongoing
investigation
we've arrived at Mount gox this is Mount
Cox right here there's no no big sign or
anything no no doesn't look like a crazy
commercial establishment despite their
legal problems Mount Cox still handles
more volume than any other exchange and
is processing around 6 million dollars
worth of bitcoin trades every day we are
last year on average of 10 000 new
customers a month January twice twenty
thousand then thirty thousand sixty
thousand one hundred fifty thousand with
what's going on it's going down but we
are reaching 100 000 new customers uh
for May that's amazing in a month in a
month so it was like but still I was
after what happened I thought that a lot
of people will go away or or don't don't
create a new account but still 100 000
new customers it's uh wow
and here we've got the office
so with everyone walking
hopefully
[Music]
Mount Cox employs 18 people
not only is Mark the CEO he's also the
CFO the lead developer and performs all
technical operations to keep the
exchange running what's it written
is that your main is that your main
program
I've got a lot of improvement which is
yeah what's your favorite programming
language really depends what I need to
do like for you took something really
quick and I don't care about performance
I use PHP if I carry templates about
performance I will use C plus plus with
QT for example but if I care a lot about
performance I will use Asm
foreign
cameras down first until we get to your
servers exactly back up okay
[Music]
getting ready to go into the Mad Cox
data center location
camera's down
[Music]
we were allowed to snap a few
photographs
one of the main issue we had during the
second bubble is that volume of trading
was too high compared to what our system
was designed to support to prevent this
is we optimized a lot of the system
can reach a big speed of 70 to 100
orders per second
the new trading engine it can handle
about 100 million orders possible
[Music]
if Mount Cox's new trading engine can
really support 100 million orders per
second it should be able to scale with
the demands of professional Traders but
with complex legal problems and
increasing competition Mark's attention
is pulled in many directions
[Music]
foreign
do you work seven days a week typically
yep
it seems that you do the majority of all
the heavy lifting literally and
to remove your shoes in the entrance
Mark is a talented man and one of the
world's biggest cities
but maybe he should stick the computer
keyboards
[Music]
okay
foreign
we are here in Northern New Hampshire
for the porcupine Freedom Festival and
this is an event to put on each year by
the free state project
basically it's just a bunch of crazy
anarcho-capitalists libertarian types in
the woods with freedom and Families
pretty much all the vendors except
Bitcoin
[Music]
it's much better when bought with
Bitcoin
thanks guys
soup salads and smoothies
I would say one-third of our sales have
been in Bitcoin it's uh 20 bucks so
you're paying Bitcoin
all right last year was our first year
accepting it
we did maybe 18 transactions 20
transactions at the most and now we're
up to close to 120.
[Music]
this community is really one of the
largest groups of people in the U.S I
think that's truly adopting Bitcoin and
using it as a currency because of what
it stands for and because of what it
enables
the world is seriously changing now and
it is changing in a very interesting
very radical decentralized and in my
opinion positive direction
shoot here it is price breaks the
all-time high
vitalik is only 19 years old but he has
a profound understanding of the
complexities of Bitcoin and a gift for
explaining them
as lead writer for Bitcoin magazine he's
been traveling the world covering
Bitcoin for the past year I'm a big fan
of the of the decentralization concept
in principle you know have well have
lots of lots of different societies
operating according to whatever whatever
people's own beliefs are
Bitcoin has unique properties and no
other system in the world has had before
it's really seems like the only
practical way forward
As you move away from cash into your
debit cards and your credit cards you
essentially are giving up a certain
degree of your privacy without even
really knowing it it's important to
understand that Bitcoin is not
automatically perfectly Anonymous but
what it does is it enables you to be
anonymous if you wish to
Eric Voorhees is the founder and part
owner of a hugely popular Bitcoin
gambling site called Satoshi dice
Satoshi dice is the first of a new breed
of provably fair betting games that use
Bitcoin
since all bets are public anyone can
verify the odds and payouts
at its peak Satoshi dice was responsible
for more Bitcoin transactions than all
other uses of Bitcoin combined
played an important role in bitcoin's
development as one of the first
applications to really test what the
Bitcoin Network could handle
recently Eric moved his entire
operations out of the U.S and into
Panama
he started a company called coinapult
that lets you send Bitcoin Via SMS and
email
I think most people at least in America
believe that when they put
a thousand dollars into their Bank the
bank is holding a thousand dollars in
its Vault for them and they don't
realize that 99 of all the dollars are
digital the fact that we have these
tokens called uh paper cash is a is the
exception to the rule people see the
cash and they think that that's what the
money is but it's all digital and it's
been that way for decades you guys moved
your business to Panama what was the
primary driver in that if you're a US
company you have to follow the Arcane
U.S regulations for all of your
customers around the world so if you do
business with some rural farmer in
Africa you're going to need to get a
Social Security number you're going to
need to get all this information that
Washington tells you is important we did
not want to have to apply the U.S
financial regulatory scheme to customers
in sub-Saharan Africa I don't think the
developed world is going to be where
Bitcoin really takes off long term
because our banking systems work
decently well many people around the
world don't have any bank accounts
whatsoever ultimately those are the
types of people who will find the most
value out of Bitcoin
one month later Eric announced that he
had sold Satoshi dice to an anonymous
investor the price
126 315 Bitcoins
worth around 11.5 million dollars
most of the new offices in the city are
in this condition all still what's
called gray not ready no internet no
electricity nothing but we actually got
one that was finished so we moved in and
we are super excited about it
you can see all the skyscrapers of new
Banks and everything getting built up
here this is a financial center for
Central America so it was fitting that
we established ourselves here as well
still setting up the office we've been
here for two weeks we're getting walls
put in we've got furniture and this is
the brains of the operation this is Mr
Ira he can program anything and you can
see all these books he's reading what do
we got here we've got cryptanalysis we
got everyday cryptography
introduction to mathematical
cryptography
I read all these of course when I was
much younger but I was trying to catch
up with me
the Bitcoin phenomenon is trying to take
control of money away from the state and
return it to individuals it's trying to
separate money and state in the same way
and for the same reasons that it was
important to separate church and state
there's a wonderful quote from one of
the Rothschilds giving me control of a
nation's money and I care not who makes
its laws
so I'm trying to play my part in that
narrative
outside of the United States billions of
people don't have access to basic
banking services
Bitcoin can level the playing field and
help bring developing nations into the
global economy
[Music]
eventually people are going to use a
currency that is as free as the internet
because people seek out Freedom wherever
they can and just as the government
can't stop the internet and the freedom
of speech can't stop Bitcoin and the
freedom of money we're just gonna have
to see how hard they try to do it
scary but it's exciting because at the
other end Freedom typically wins I just
have to see how long it takes to get
there
[Music]
as summer rolled on the Bitcoin industry
continued to flourish
it's hard to remember the days where I
was running this thing out of my
basement and it was like one or two
people and like bit instant was just a
domain name Charlie and bit instant
moved into their new offices I always
wonder if Satoshi knew that he was going
to build something that would like
Foster my companies like this where
we're actually like company jobs based
on something that someone we don't know
wrote a paper on it's kind of creepy if
you think about it like I wonder if he's
like kind of watching us right now or
something
in San Francisco Jared and tradehill had
moved into their new space as well
sounds funny it's not 100 million dollar
market anymore
it's currently on that
more professional people learning the
space and they're expecting to deal with
other professionals
but just as things were ramping up
Regulators started taking a closer look
at Bitcoin
he's from Bitcoin or
Lori could be
these have been subpoa subpoenaed by New
York's Department of Financial Services
can't be a good thing
[Music]
bid instant bit pay coinbase and
Winklevoss Capital were all issued
subpoenas we want to make sure that as
this Enterprise grows and if it does
become a place where a lot of people are
engaging in financial transactions that
we have sufficient Protections in place
with increased pressure in banking
compliance issues bid instant was forced
to suspend services
[Music]
Jared faced similar battles
due to a lack of Regulation many banks
decided to cut ties with Bitcoin
companies
without a U.S bank account tradehill
can't operate and Jared was forced to
pull the plug
[Music]
regulation typically evolves much more
slowly than Innovation and regulations
cannot keep Pace with the pace of
innovation
explaining Bitcoin to a bank feel
to Barnes Noble
until lawmakers catch up startups like
tradehill and bid instant are left out
on a limb
Banks do not want to bank Bitcoin
companies when you have regulation you
can comply with it when you don't have
you know regulation they're not exactly
sure and if the banks aren't sure they
just default to no new regulation takes
at least one year to develop propose and
adopt and in many cases it can take much
longer than that
[Music]
I won't let this go
I'll fight till the end for Bitcoin
whether I have to work on the street or
sell lemonade the coin is going to
succeed one way or another and I'm going
to be a part of it
over the past several months the Bitcoin
mining landscape has changed
significantly
[Music]
when I started Bitcoin mining was a
hobby for geeks
now it's big business in order to
continue Mining and continue playing in
the game and be competitive and be
profitable I would have to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars on gear
the 18 miners I ordered from Avalon
never arrived
and the units from butterfly Labs took
over a year to ship
by the time I got them Bitcoin mining
was so competitive that I would never be
able to mine back all the coins I used
to buy them
see that computer that computer makes
Bitcoins and this is
um all the other computers that are
making Bitcoins too and it goes straight
up in the line up in the air and that's
because there's a lot of people that are
making Bitcoins with computers like that
as my new units are arriving I'm selling
them for Bitcoins to try to recoup what
I can you don't mind grabbing those
other cables I'm not coming back up okay
I'm taking a pretty big hit
but overall the mining experience has
still been worth it
[Music]
days may be over but I'm still very
involved with Bitcoin with Bitcoin it's
a money system where it's backed by math
it's backed by the laws of mathematics
and by the rules of the protocol I keep
thinking that there's got to be an
easier way to just set up a secondary
protocol to trade private Keys every
time I log on I see another dot on China
and I'm like this is why right now the
price is gone
the price is nearing 150 again
many attributed to the explosion of
bitcoin's popularity in China what's
happened recently is Chinese people have
really come and adopted Bitcoin
as a culture as a nation Chinese people
are Keen to learn about things that are
on the internet things that involve math
and science
we think that China can really
contribute in the space and help bring
Bitcoin to the mainstream
Germany is another part of the world
where Bitcoin has found a home it's
starting to get normal if one person a
day comes in and buys a coffee with
Bitcoins people are looking for a new
way of paying and not through banks and
not with yours not with dollars
something new
the German Ministry of Finance even
became the first governing body to
officially classify Bitcoin as private
money I believe if we want to get some
justice back into our society we should
reduce the importance of the banks
Bitcoin is banking without banks so here
we go
[Music]
they shut down what it's calling the
most sophisticated Internet site in the
business of selling hard drugs including
heroin cocaine and LSD
in the Sci-Fi section of the San
Francisco Public Library undercover
agents surprised the young man quietly
working on his laptop
they arrested a 29 year old software
engineer named Ross Albright and accused
him of being The Mastermind behind the
Silk Road
people have always tied the Silk Road to
it media has always tied the Silk Road
to it as if like Silk Road is Bitcoin
but it's not this may be a sign that
Bitcoin is growing up
it's funny my friend just iMed me and
said you know it's still core graduated
and the government seized 3.6 million
dollars in Bitcoin is there a way to
invalidate Bitcoins I replied to know
government is now
invested in Bitcoin
people are starting to finally realize
that Bitcoin has nothing to do with how
people use it it's just money it's like
gold
of course not everyone thinks Bitcoin is
the way of the future
Bitcoin will not be able to survive or
Thrive without
becoming legitimate I don't see it
having a serious place in our financial
system
they're really good reasons why we have
central banks that have the power to put
out Financial fires by printing money
I'm
worried about the technology as Darth
Vader once said don't put all your faith
in technology
I think 10 years from now we'll look
back on this and just kind of chuckle at
the Bitcoin fad oh yeah remember Bitcoin
oh yeah I remember that
it's Financial Freedom come on bro this
is the new world bro
others are more optimistic I think
within 10 years you're going to have a
lot of people using Bitcoin but they're
not going to realize that they're using
it because it's going to be a protocol
that's embedded underneath whatever
Financial Service they're using today
and by Bitcoin being open source it's
what can allow all these different
mobile wallets and all these Financial
Technologies to all talk to each other
especially around the world
whoever the hell Satoshi was he should
go down and history as one of the
greatest people or groups of people that
ever existed this is a technology that
mankind has needed for thousands of
years people have been dealing with
monetary Shenanigans since the Roman
Empire clipping gold coins and finally
people can escape it I'm
cautious to try to predict the future we
don't really know
I tend to be a technological Optimist I
see the the democratization of
Technology just being a really positive
thing and I think that's a really
powerful force that is really only just
beginning
foreign
[Music]
recently as the price has been floating
around 200 again you know I have a lot
of friends that have that have asked me
you know are you going to cash out some
of your Bitcoins now you know the price
is really high you should you know get
some dollars out of it and
I kind of tell them no like don't you
see it
[Music]
I've met so many interesting people and
there seems to be one thing that kind of
binds a lot of them together and that is
that they're willing to face opposition
and follow through on the ideas that
they believe in
the people who try the crazy ideas often
fail and then everybody likes to point
their fingers and laugh and say that was
such a stupid idea but once in a while
it works out
I think Bitcoin is proving to be one of
those things
[Music]
the decision to bring virtual currency
within the scope of our regulatory
framework should be viewed as a positive
development for this sector I'm here to
testify because I believe that digital
currency represents one of the most
important Technical and economic
Innovations of our time we are
enthusiastic about the potential of
virtual currencies and the digital
economy for social good
[Music]
this latest generation of technology
which we're talking about today takes
things to a whole new level there's a
rather a bit of a shared responsibility
here in trying to figure out how to make
this work it is a little strange that
the Bitcoin we don't know who the
Creator is and so
um that often conjures up the idea that
there's some risk here that we have not
you don't think it was Al Gore to you
[Laughter]
if you think a little broadly this could
again have huge huge implications
foreign
[Music]
was the year Bitcoin first entered the
mainstream and 2014 got off to a
dramatic start
just as we were wrapping things up on
our film Charlie Schram was arrested
after returning from a Bitcoin
conference in Amsterdam
he could be facing up to 30 years in
prison on charges related to his
activities at bid instant
in JFK you walk right off the plane and
you go straight to customs about three
agents in front of me and then four
agents behind me said Mr Shrum please
come with us
they took me to an interrogating room
told me that I'm being arrested on
federal crimes money laundering running
an unlicensed money transmission
business and failing to file suspicious
activity reports the indictment alleged
that Charlie had sold Bitcoins to a
reseller that operated on the Silk Road
what sucks is the house arrest you know
I have to pretty much be here all the
time every day I can't even go outside
unless I'm going to my lawyer's office
which is once or twice a week
I pretty much lost my freedom lost
everything that I've built over the past
year
Charlie's arrest wasn't the only bad
news that rocked the community in the
new year
for months there had been rumors that
mount Cox had become insolvent and in
February the site went offline
the rumors turned out to be true
[Music]
Mount Cox had reportedly been hacked and
nearly half a billion dollars worth of
bitcoin were missing
Mark was forced to step down as CEO and
mount Cox went into bankruptcy
a national magazine claims to have
identified the mysterious founder of the
worldwide digital currency called
Bitcoin tonight he is speaking out but
he says he has nothing whatsoever to do
with Bitcoin why did you create Bitcoin
sir okay no no questions right now
sir can we ask you about Bitcoin
okay I'm not involved in Bitcoin okay
who's involved wait a minute
I want big one
oh okay yeah this would be good
cheese I have some water
hey uh was yours
Newsweek claimed the creator of Bitcoin
had not used a suit in him
they connected the dots to a 64 year old
Japanese man living in Los Angeles
named Dorian Prentice Satoshi Nakamoto
Nakamoto immediately denied the
allegations and said he'd tell a story
to the first reporter who agreed to buy
him lunch
the main reason I'm here is to clear my
name that I have nothing to do with
Bitcoin nothing to do with developing
I was just an engineer doing something
else as the media frenzy escalated
newsweek's claims started to unravel
holes in the story led many to believe
it was nothing more than Sensational
journalism
there was no conclusive evidence tying
Dorian to bitcoin
amidst the uncertainty on that same day
a comment suddenly appeared on satoshi's
Long dormant profile page which read
I am not Dorian Nakamoto
[Music]
maybe we'll never know who created
bitcoin
but the truth is
it doesn't really matter
[Music]
Bitcoin belongs to everyone
and the future is ours to build
[Music]
for that hundred thousand dollars on
Market orders right now all right let's
do it come on come on why what's gonna
happen buy 100K worth of Bitcoins right
now why do it I don't want to do it do
it you owe me a hundred thousand dollars
do it I'll send you a hundred thousand
dollars no you buy buy 100
and I can't floating goggs for volume
closing down for Satoshi Square all
right does this look right
TW yep yep okay and I do 0.2
0.18 this is for Bitcoin t-shirts
great doing business with you I'm gonna
to wear your shirt proudly do it that's
one thing that's interesting about
Bitcoin it's like how do you like
declare losses you know you point to two
transactions that happen on the internet
and you tell the IRS that you own that
you know oh are you still on that and I
lost the private key like you know and
then if you really do lose it how do you
write it off for taxes and stuff that's
going to be interesting
[Applause]
okay guys we're gonna play a special
version of hopscotch called Bitcoin
blockchain hop shot
oh you lost all your Bitcoins
who is Satoshi Nakamoto
hey
girls are not tell you but yeah oh do
you know uh Maybe not maybe oh
you know I have a Bitcoin and a half
myself now which I think probably in 10
years means I'll be really rich
when you think about it hard enough on a
global scale this is a Net game for
Humanity